my ultimate French breakfast isn't
complex or flashy it's just simple
elegant and delicious the secret to a
really good Madeleine is its light
fluffy delicious and it's perfect with
the coffee in the morning so melt the
butter gently next crack three eggs
that's one of the most exciting things
about living in Paris there was always
something there and that little pastry
shop that used to live above could
incorporate the sugar and then give that
a really good whisk because it's
important to incorporate some air now
the secret to whisking is a big
beautiful balloon whisk the bigger the
balloon whisk the more aeration you'll
get in the mixture so the best thing to
do is just go from left to right and
then change hands every 15 or 20 seconds
so your hands never get tired and tilt
the bowl to your advantage as well now
you can see the mixture starter areas
that's almost double in size the more
you whisk this the lighter it becomes so
it starts to almost look like a light
whipped cream gone is that dark rich egg
yolk color beautiful once the eggs and
sugar become pale creamy and thick
sifting the self-raising flour
saving the flower now I'm given my
Madeline's at twist but adding poppy
seeds for a crunch and lemon for flavor
zest of a lemon in their generous on the
lemon lime is wonderful orange zest
again beautiful I've even made pink
grapefruit Madeline's with poppy seeds
delicious but lemon for me is the best
put the melted butter down the side of
the bowl so it cools down even more and
then combine start mixing that in it's
really important at this stage that we
don't beat the mixture I want to keep
that nice aerated texture across the
Madeleine mix so I'm gonna use a spatula
now and just gently mix my butter in now
give that a good mix but when they say
that the longer you make the mix up in
advance the higher they raise in the
oven look at that it looks beautiful
leave that to sit there and will butter
and line our molds you can make these in
little miniature Yorkshire pudding
moulds I've even seen Madeline's being
cooked and expresso cups so if you
haven't got the traditional Madeleine
tray Yorkshire pudding trays are just as
good lightly butter the inside of the
tray take a tablespoon of flour and the
secret now is to lie in the mould with a
flower that stops any chance of the
Madeleine sticking tap the sieve into
all the little grooves
this was ensure that they'll come out
instantly then all you do then is just
stand up the tray and tap it two or
three times and you'll see the flower
roll out
so there you go the baking sheet lined
Billy no excess butter and no excess
flour the beauty of this recipe is that
you can make it the night before and
then simply bake it in the morning when
you're ready to go put the mixture into
a jug to make it really easy to pour
into the tin give it a little stir so
you've got that nice even distribution
of those poppy seeds and just gently
lovely firm up to the top Oh beautiful
so much easier pouring this from a joke
because you get the exact amount in in
the oven 180 degrees do not open that
door before 10 minutes and wait that
wonderful surprise smell amazing now a
little tap inside of the tray once you
just all pop out use freedom that smell
is unique that nice soft crisp outside
with lovely fragrant fluffy Center and
the secret of a great Madeleine as the
French would swear by it is this lovely
little mound on top they call it a
nipple but that is the confirmation that
is perfect my poppy and lemon Madeline's
are a sophisticated continental start to
the day and take me straight back to
Paris
they have efficient over the salt get
your salt and just start back in you can
sulk reform I oven chips with a twist
simply peel slice